Hey guys,
You know in this day and age that we live in,
Christian men need to stand on God's Word.
And believe in it.
Trust in it.
More than anything else.
We need men who live by
God-confidence and not self-confidence.
We are in a spiritual battle every day and
you cannot let up for even a second.
You need to put on the armor of God
and fight with truth against all the
lies that are out there in the world.
All the distractions.
And you need to run your
race until the end to receive the crown of life.
But how can you fight if you don't know the truth?
God's Word?
Do you know His Word?
Do you read it?
Do you study it?
Do you live it?
Do you use it as part of
the armor of God to fight back against the devil?
Because there are a lot of clever people in this
world who mix the truth with lies.
It can even be 99 percent truth
and 1 percent lie and it can distract you.
It can deceive you, to go in the wrong direction.
You know, the devil, when he tried to tempt Jesus,
he used the truth but he used it in the wrong way.
And Jesus didn't fall for his attacks,
because Jesus is the Word of God.
He couldn't deceive Jesus.
And what did Jesus do to fight back?
He quoted scripture every single time.
And the devil couldn't fight with that.
And that's why he left and
that's you need to do as well.
[2 Timothy 3:16-17]
He didn't say some of scripture was breathed
out by God - not 99 percent - he said all
scripture was breathed out by God.
Do you understand how amazing this is?
The God of the universe.
It is His Word.
What He chose to reveal to us.
He wants us to know - understand
- and live by His truth.
Man, this is so powerful and unfortunately a
lot of people today are being distracted by the
busyness of this world.
And the devil.
And they don't study God's Word anymore.
So I want to plead with you today,
to study God's Word.
And to help you to do that,
to fight all the battles on this road
of sanctification that you are on.
I want to give you five crucial important
Bible verses that I believe every man,
Christian man, should know.
Let's start with the first one.
[1 Corinthians 16:13]
Man, I love this verse.
It says that we have to be watchful.
Are you?
Are you always on guard, looking out?
Because we are in a battle.
Whether you like it or not.
And you need to be watchful.
You need to be careful.
You need to be on guard, being able to see
when evil is attacking you or your family.
You also need to be able to discern,
to watch out there in the world to
see what darkness is doing and then
to shine your light to expose it.
[Ephesians 5:11]
And then verse 15 says:
[Ephesians 5:15-16]
So, how do you do this practically, standing
on guard, being watchful, shining your light?
Well, right after Paul says in 1
Corinthians 16 to be watchful, he says this:
A lot of men today are not doing this anymore.
They're like Jell-o.
You know, easily being distracted.
Easily being deceived.
Because they don't follow sound doctrine anymore.
[Titus 2:1]
[2 Timothy 1:13]
To live and teach sound doctrine,
you need to know the Bible.
Do you?
Or do you just follow
what is "in" at the moment, what is trending, or
listening to preachers who preach to itching ears,
just sharing motivational messages?
There are many false teachers out there
who just preach to people what they want to
hear, what their fleshly natures want to hear.
And for a lot of churches,
it is just a business model.
They don't even preach the gospel anymore, what
God wants them to preach. They're too scared
to say certain things because then people will
leave the church and take their money with them.
And it is causing many churches to be lukewarm
because of half-truths and motivational messages.
Not preaching sound doctrine.
When I grew up, the church was so different,
even here in South Africa.
My dad was a preacher.
He lived the way he preached.
And I knew the fundamental doctrines of scripture.
Today, if you ask Christians
about it, they don't even know.
Let me ask you - do you know the fundamental
doctrines of scripture, or even important things.
For example, the doctrine of man?
Of God?
Of Christ and the Holy Spirit?
The application of redemption?
In other words, what is justification -
sanctification - regeneration - the new covenant?
How to live in the Spirit and important
things like how to be a real man?
A good father, son, and
husband according to scripture?
You see, men are being attacked from
all sides these days, with lies.
But how can you know the lies
if you do not know the truth?
And it it saddens me to see that
so many men run after motivational
messages because that is what they want,
but it cannot bring lasting change.
Because it is only the Word
of God that can set you free.
God's Word can change you if you read it.
If you absorb it and act on it.
Which brings us to the next Bible verse:
Every Christian man should know:
[James 1:22]
Every man must decide if he wants to
follow Jesus - the world - or his own will.
If you want to be a true reborn Christian,
you need to follow Jesus Christ.
Because He is the truth, the Word of God.
[John 1:1]
If you follow Him, if you truly love Jesus Christ
with everything that is in
you, you will obey His word.
[John 14:15]
Please listen to me today.
You cannot just follow certain parts
of scripture, certain parts of the Bible that
fits in with your lifestyle and leave the rest.
You either commit to God fully and change
your lifestyle, according to scripture,
or, you're deceiving yourself.
And you're a lukewarm Christian.
Which means you're a fake Christian.
[2 Corinthians 10:5-6]
You see, you take every thought captive.
That's on your soul level, your own thoughts
that come with your emotions.
Your own will.
You take those thoughts captive and you
bring it under the Lordship of Jesus Christ.
That is what it means to
now live through the Spirit.
Because it is the Spirit that has set you
free from the law of sin and death, meaning,
if you live in the Spirit, you will not sin.
You will obey God's Word.
Not just oh, because you have
to, but because you love Him.
You become a doer of God's Word, not
just a hearer, deceiving yourself.
[1 Peter 3:7]
So when you read this, and you realize because the
Holy Spirit will convict you, you realize, man,
a few minutes ago I wasn't really nice to my wife.
I might have been right, what I said,
but the way I said it was from the flesh.
You don't just brush it off, continue to read
because, oh you want to spend our time with God.
You have unrepented sin.
You need to stop reading the Bible there and then.
You stand up, you go to your wife and you say,
I'm sorry, forgive me, the way that I
talked you was wrong and then after that,
you come back to God's Word.
Continue the Bible study.
[John 14: 21]
If you pray to God and you're
wondering why does God not answer you?
Why does He not talk to you?
This might be it.
Because you want to practice
religion from the flesh.
You have unresolved sin in your life.
And you haven't asked those
people and God to forgive you.
You are not taking the unresolved
sin in your life seriously.
You need to break with sin and take it
seriously and that takes us to the next verse.
[James 4:17]
Wow, it cannot be more clear than this.
You need to break with sin.
We know and we understand that when we
repented, when we became a reborn Christian,
when God justified us as righteous, when we
became His child, God forgave us for all our sins.
But after that, as we continue to walk on the
road of sanctification, through the Holy Spirit,
we need to walk and live holy.
Because we need to be led by the
Holy Spirit so when we do fall in sin, we
come back to the Father and we say Father,
I have sinned.
I am sorry.
And then our relationship is
restored and we continue the walk.
Being under the New Covenant means that we
are under the law of the Spirit and that
means we need to obey the Holy Spirit.
Obey God in everything that we do.
[ Romans 8:1-2]
What is sin?
In its essence, sin is not obeying God.
It is not like a lot of people still
think it is just about obeying the
Ten Commandments from the Old Testament.
Yeah, we have to obey God's law, but under the
New Covenant it means we are under the Spirit,
which means we need to obey God in everything
that we do, meaning we are led by the Spirit.
We need to walk - live - act in the Spirit.
The moment we don't do that,
it means we are disobeying God.
And we are acting in the flesh.
And then we will bring forth sin.
[Galatians 5:16-18]
So, if you live according to the Spirit,
it means you're under the Spirit.
You are being obedient to God's Word.
You're being obedient to God, right?
Then you will not sin.
Now let me be very direct with you.
And let me ask you - are you
still living in the flesh?
Let's take a look at some of
the the works of the flesh.
[Galatians 5:19]
Let's be real.
There are men out there there who
are claiming to be Christian men but they boast
about how drunk they are getting every week,
the girls they meet and the sin they do.
This is not the Christian life
under the Holy Spirit.
You might go to church
on Sundays and claim to be a Christian.
Even say that you're a Christian from birth
because you grew up in a Christian home,
that does not mean you are a Christian.
If you truly came to Christ, if you had an
encounter with the living God, He changed you.
You are a new creation.
His Spirit is in you.
And will convict you of that sin.
You will not continue to live
in it and not feel anything.
You will feel terrible about it.
Tears will run down your face
and you will say God, forgive me.
And you will not want to do it again.
Some people say Daniel, why are
you so serious about it?
Because this is serious.
I'm saying this with a lot of love.
But you need to understand that it is
serious because your soul is at stake.
And a lot of you who are watching this
video might be on the way to hell.
Let's continue with the verse.
[Galatians 5:21]
And as I am also warning you guys today.
Please listen.
I'm saying this to you because I don't want
you to deceive yourself like I used to do.
I was a lukewarm Christian.
I told a lot of people that I'm a Christian
but I wasn't until the death of my second brother.
And God opened my eyes to the truth and I
realized I'm a sinner.
I'm on the way to hell.
And I reached out to Him and
I said, God please change me.
Forgive me.
Make me a new creation.
So today I'm asking you to
be truthful to yourself.
Examine yourself to see whether
you truly are in the faith.
[Galatians 5:22]
Verse 22 then says but the fruit of the Spirit.
meaning if you are a spiritually reborn Christian,
you will have the Holy Spirit in you.
Then you will automatically produce this fruit.
[Galatians 5:23-25]
If you want to live in the Spirit,
keep in step with the Spirit,
then you need to deny yourself the fleshly
life and that brings us to to the next verse.
[Matthew 16:24]
Following Christ does not just mean,
oh I'll believe in Jesus Christ,
just so I can have my ticket into heaven.
But you still continue to live exactly the same,
there's no change in you.
No.
Saying you believe in Jesus Christ
meant that He revealed Himself to you.
You accepted Him truly and He changed you.
You repented of your sins, you turned away
from who you were.
180° change.
You were transformed by God Himself.
The God who spoke the whole
universe into existence.
If you truly became a reborn
Christian, it is a miracle.
You cannot change yourself.
It is God who changes us - so that
we will never be the same again.
[2 Corinthians 5:17]
You become spiritually alive and a whole new
spiritual world opens up to you, where God
transformed how you think, feel, live.
He transforms everything because now
you are something new.
Something different.
For those of you who do not
understand what I'm talking about,
it's also almost like you are now a super
human, because before you only had your
body with the five senses.
And only your soul, right?
Your emotions - your intellect - your own will -
but now you have received a new spiritual nature.
God's Spirit.
He sealed you with His
Spirit and that changes everything in you.
And this is also where God starts to
reveal to you your identity in Christ.
You can only have a relationship with God
through the spiritual nature and in truth
because God is Spirit and He is the truth.
And man, when you start to understand this,
when you start to walk within this truth,
and you say, Father, here I am.
You are the potter, I am the clay.
Take out everything that is not
right and show me who I truly am.
Who you made me to be.
And work through me.
Do your work through me for Your glory.
Not for my own.
If you come to this point of complete
surrender, then you start to understand
that this is exactly where God wants you,
before He can truly use you for His glory.
[Proverbs 3:5]
When you come to this point and you
see God's will for your life daily,
He starts to reveal it to you, and you
start to understand what your purpose is.
Then you realize that all your plans
led you nowhere and pale in comparison
to what God has in store for you, because
He knows you better than you know yourself.
He knows what you are capable of and what you
can accomplish in the future. This is where
you find meaning and fulfillment while
you live with eyes fully fixed on Jesus.
Where you find peace and all spiritual blessings.
You know, when I talk to certain Christians and I
tell them we have already received all spiritual
blessings in Christ, some of them are like, what?
What are those?
Because people do not read scripture anymore.
They don't understand this.
Being a Christian is not just
about finding salvation, it's about finding
true life and meaning in Jesus Christ.
[Ephesians 1:3]
Man, this is so special.
When you reach this point, you start to realize,
man, life is not about me at all.
It's about Jesus.
And it has been about Him all along.
All the answers you search for.
This world - everything is about Jesus.
And all you ever really needed was Him.
To abide in Him, to truly
understand what that means.
[John 15:5-7]
You start to understand that
this is what life is all about.
This is where you find true joy and peace.
The things that humankind search for...
for thousands of years.
The answer was - is - and
always will be - Jesus Christ.
It's amazing to think that the
world was created through Jesus for
Jesus and that He sustains everything.
And He is far beyond what we can even try to
comprehend with our small three pound brains.
And still this God chose to
come to us to be a personal God,
to show us who He is because He
wants a relationship with us.
[John 15:11]
When you reach this point
of truly abiding in Christ,
you don't worry and have anxiety or stress about
the normal things that still affect people today.
You start to see the whole picture of life.
The devil.
This world can do nothing to you.
Because you are in Christ.
The normal things that used to influence you and
that still influence other people today do not
influence you anymore.
Let me explain.
There are people who claim to be
Christians but they still live according
to their own will, focused on the self-life.
Living selfishly, always having issues and
struggles, complaining about this, complaining
about that, complaining about everything.
They say things like - oh, this is just who I am.
So don't expect me to change.
Or, this is my child and I
will raise him as I want to.
Or, it is my money so I will do it as I want to.
Or, I'm not going to forgive this person.
They need to come to me or I am never wrong or
just do what I told you because I'm your husband
or I'm your father.
I-I-I
So full of pride and God hates pride.
You need to come to the end of that I.
To the end of yourself.
That I needs to be broken by Christ.
So that you can say like Jesus.
[Luke 22:42]
You know, all those things that
you feel so "I- I- I" about.
Even the I He has given that to you.
He has given you life.
He's given you a self-determining will,
because He wants you to choose Him out of love.
He wants you to put Him first in everything.
To say like Paul in Galatians 2:20.
[Galatians 2:20]
You know, certain men don't really have these
issues, because they struggle with being a good
father, or a good son, or a good husband.
Or they struggle to be this or that
because of the reasons they think.
It is because of the self-life.
That is why they struggle when you
deny yourself, including your past.
You sort it out with God once and for all.
You repent, ask Him to forgive everything.
He does.
He doesn't
even think about it anymore.
It makes you a new creation.
You start to live in the spirit.
You are a new creation.
You need to understand what that means.
It means that you are not the same anymore.
You need to forgive yourself, you need to move on.
When you do, you start to live through the Spirit
and you have true love in you. Unconditional
agape love, because it is the love that God
has given to you through the Spirit.
The love that you now have for God.
And for other people.
And that will help you to be a good father,
a good husband, a good son, a good everything.
Because you do it through the Spirit now.
Your new nature.
And that takes us to the next verse:
[Matthew 7:12]
Now many of you know that this
is also called the golden rule.
And if you follow this golden rule, you will
automatically also obey most of the other laws.
For example, you won't kill someone
because you don't want someone to
kill you. You won't steal something because
you don't want someone to steal from you.
You won't curse or swear at someone because
you don't want someone to do that to you.
When you receive the agape love from
God, through the Spirit that is in you,
you start to truly love other people.
Because it is God that is helping
you and loving people through you.
That is how you are able to be the
light and start to look so differently at other
people, realizing that they are sinners, right?
You don't love the sin but you love
them and you want them to be safe.
You start to live a life that is unselfish.
Selfless.
You realize that people love them just as much
as He loves you and wants them to be saved.
That is why so many mature Christians truly
love other people and want to help them.
And that is how you will live as
well, if God's Spirit is in you.
[Philippians 2:3]
So many Christians out there are are so selfish
because they still live according to their
self-life and it causes a lot of hurt.
Unnecessary hurt.
But if you live through the Spirit, through
God's love, it changes everything. Because then
you actually start to put yourself in their shoes
and understand how they feel about certain things.
My wife, if I were in her position,
what would she need from me right now?
My son, if I were in his position, how
would I want my father to speak to me?
You see, you start to look at things
from their perspective and then together
with the Spirit in you that gives you the
ability to truly speak into their lives,
you start to think and act differently.
Because you first ask God how do
you want me to handle this situation?
What do you want me to give to this person?
What do they need from me right now?
It is not about you at all anymore,
because you love God's Word.
And because He is in you,
you start to obey verses like these.
To think of others as more
significant than yourself.
Not to live a selfish life.
And you start to especially take
verses like these seriously.
[1 Timothy 5:8]
[1 Peter 3:7]
[Colossians 3: 21]
So you start with your household.
You lead with gentleness.
With love.
There are too many Christian
men out there who are harsh.
Too harsh with their kids.
Too legalistic.
And you're pushing them away from God.
How dare you.
Yes, you need to teach the
truth in love and bring them to Christ.
You need to be the example.
You need to be as Jesus.
You need to follow in the footsteps of Jesus
and be to your family as Christ is to the church.
That is a huge responsibility but you can do
it through Christ that gives you strength.
You need to follow God's will for your family.
And it doesn't matter how you were brought up
and you have excuses like, oh I didn't have a
good example like this or that.
Well, you have the most
perfect example: Jesus Himself.
And through the Spirit, you can do it.
Through the flesh we cannot.
We will struggle.
We need to learn to do it through the Spirit.
You can be a great father.
You can be a great son.
And you can be a great husband.
But then there comes a point where you also
understand, it's not just about your family,
but about everyone God sends on your path.
Even people you don't like, with your self-life.
[Matthew 5:43}
Do you understand?
If you only care about your own family
members then you are just the same as unbelievers
who care about their family members and they don't
care about other people outside their family.
They always just put their family first and they
will even murder, kill, steal, and bribe
just to get ahead for their own family.
And that's why we have so much suffering in
the world because people commit terrible acts
just to try and help their own family
but they're willing to do those acts
against other people with other families.
But you are supposed to be different.
You are a true reborn Christian.
Will look after your own family but
also care about other people out there.
You will want people to be saved.
You will want to make disciples of all people
and all nations because God's love is in you.
[Matthew 5:48]
Now, let me just pray for you.
Father, I want to ask you to please bless
this person who is watching this video.
Please change them.
Create a fire within them for You.
To truly follow You.
Radical discipleship.
To follow Jesus.
You.
No matter the cost to truly love
other people out there as well.
Please Father, bless them.
Use this video, this sermon, for Your glory.
Amen.
If you
want to grow in Christ and need help, please
watch these videos here and it will help you.
God loves you, and I love you, too.
Bye.